We would need to add 9, 36, 4, and 25 to complete each of these squares. Great
thinking if you found these numbers. For the first polynomial, we can think
about having one block that's area is x squared, and then six other tiles that
have an area of x. We take the 6x and we split three of the x's over here and
three of the x's over here. So we'll have x squared plus six x's, and then
we'll need to add at 9 one pieces to complete our perfect square. So, when
thinking about completing the square, it's best if this b term is even. This
allows us to split up the x's, so we have half of them here and half of them
here. And then we can figure out how many one pieces we would need to add to
complete our perfect square down here. For this first polynomial, it turns out
that was 9. For the second one, we draw a similar figure as the one before, and
we'll find out that we'll need to add 36 one tiles to complete the square. For
this third polynomial, we said we had negative 4x here. So, we'll have our x
squared like before, and then, we'll have negative 4 x's. So negative 2x and
negative 2x, which makes negative 4x. So, if we were to lay out these tiles, we
could see that we would need to add four more one pieces to complete the
square. We know that this diagram also makes sense in terms of multiplication.
We know x times x equals x squared, and x times negative 1 equals negative x.
We have this negative x four times. Once here, once here, once here, and once
here. And finally, for these 4 one pieces, we have a sidelength of negative 1
here and a sidelength of negative 1 here. So, negative 1 times negative 1 would
equal a positive 1. We have this positive 1 four times, so we know we have to
add 4 one tiles to complete our square.